four key is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him woody
we have a situation I am NOT a toy I was
paper soup salad maybe chili and then
the trash but we've gotta get pork of
bourbon
you guys are have been you are the
benchmark now I've read like you know
stories in you know boys don't like him
too much no but they can say with a 97
percent on Rotten Tomatoes that that's a
big deal yeah oh I'm sure Toy Story 4 is
gonna rank rank right up there what
could we do to make sure that quarter
century we've been with Woody and Buzz
in our lives what is it about these two
characters and the relationship that
they have with each other that has
helped them endure to where they mean so
much to people I'm gonna give it first
to Pixar in writing and developing the
characters let's give it that first
thing I will say secondly it's there
actually is a connection between these
two individuals at least I I really
admire this guy and want to be his
friend and have you become friends and
it translates into that it does it
translates into buzz he really does like
the guy he liked him from I see no
intelligent life anywhere from that
moment he goes oh look at that little
cowboy I kind of like that and he's full
of bravado but he kinda likes this
cowboy because he's this seems the new
she's the sheriff you know I'm just a
soldier so he this is my commanding
officer and so there's this connection
I've always liked that thing and it they
when the first Toy Story came out that's
the first thing I said to all the people
that were going I don't know about this
it does it look weird cuz computer
animator I said this friendship is great
Tim came into my life just like Buzz
came into Woody's you know it's like
what first of all I looked right at stop
telling stop talking stop it stop it
stop talking and now we seek each other
out all the time no we kind of talking
to code you know there was kind of kind
of way but he's right
Pixar the everybody who's ever worked on
any Toy Story movie does not take their
responsibilities lightly in order to
test this to shape it and not put it out
until there's a reason to and there it's
the reason because it's done and
it will live up to the imprimatur of all
the other Toy Story movies for movies in
right now I have to ask you do you have
a favorite moment from the films as hard
as it would be to pick one unfortunately
two nits
whenever he's quiet I'm not in it
but when buzz realizes he's a toy
any sits and he sits up in the attic and
he slumps down and they close in on him
and I'm good I'm brilliant I was
actually saying it and go look at how
good I'm acting I went wait a minute
that's nothing to do with me I'm not
it's it's an animator did it but I loved
that moment that it honest on his little
face that happened and funniest ones
when he says you are a toy and I shut
the visor when you were a sad strange
little man and you have my pity that's
probably what I do it all I vibe it all
the time they're my neighbors is mine is
at the end of Toy Story 3 and it's a
silent moment they are all going to go
meet their doom they are all slowly
being pushed into the fiery refuse bin
and they they look to each other and
they reach out for each other
when that when that happened I just said
this is in a high country here that I I
am so emotionally invested in inanimate
toy object that have so much more
Humanity in them than I see in the
course of my rabbit of the day what that
that moment alone is like this is
something out of you're a winner again
two masterpieces of literature
you know you've embodied these
characters for so long did you ever have
like you ever shout something out in the
house and your family goes you know
you're not woody or you know that's
something buzz would know just that my
family says you are so woody yeah which
is you know they don't mean that as we
love you and you're adorable Thank You
buzz like I've heard that oh really you
know sometimes it worked or I've done it
on sets movies I'll say something go
what do we Buzz Light you're all of a
sudden I go no I just I just happen to
get into a deeper register I do that
cool come on guys you know I get into
that kind of thing is like oh come on
guys real really are you come on guys so
four key in this film going through a
bit of an existential crisis give us
some of your tips for anyone going
through an exit
central crisis oh man
yes I can relate to four keys
existential crisis because I feel like
he's asking why am I here I'm asking how
did I get here
I'm as overwhelmed as four Kia's I never
thought I'd be here I'm thinking
somebody made a massive mistake and it's
gonna pull me out of this at any moment
but I would say like he just oh man I
would somebody actually told me once
like when you kind of feel like you're
in that kind of existential place just
start like touching things around you
like okay here's some denim here's some
wood chair I'm here I'm here
and I think four keys always he's doing
a lot that too like what's going on you
know I was gonna ask you what it's like
to voice the worst-looking toy that
Disney has ever produced
but worse to you but I feel like it's
not really fair to say that because you
know just seeing how kids are connecting
to forky and my kids are like loving the
flow I'm so glad so what do you think it
is about 40 that people are connecting
to so much is it the simplicity of the
character what is it I do think it's a
simplicity the character and he because
I think not only is he made simply but
he sees life simply he's very much like
a child he's a blank slate he's always
asking the questions he doesn't
understand the rules of the universe
humans walk in people dropped characters
dropped to the ground he's like why you
guys dropped on the ground
somebody says Bo Peep he's like what's a
bow you know he doesn't understand
anything and I think he has a freedom to
ask questions for some reason there's a
shame attached to people asking
questions many times it's like he's just
so free to be like what's this what's
this like we need to do that more you
know he's constantly curious he has all
that wonder all the time you know
curious to know what was your origin
story for 40 they did bring me up to
Pixar you know when they asked me would
I be interested in I'm like me yeah
check yes
but they showed me a picture of work and
I was like ah not what I imagined but
the more that they talked about him and
just his obvious simplicity but also
this whole concept of
he felt like his whole life goal was I'm
made for the trash
I made the help people eat soup and
chili and then I'm going to the trash
and woody steps in and he's like you
have a greater purpose you have value
and if I mean not to go
you know Metta with it but it's like if
anybody thinks that's their only path if
anybody sees themselves that way no you
have tremendous value and a huge purpose
favorite Toy Story moment in the
franchise do you have um God really
should be prepared for this question for
some reason it might because my daughter
was 4 when the last one came out but
it's I have just such a memory of them
and that furnace heading but like it's
also the way that they were like we're
doing this together
we're doing this together because I to
me what has made people gravitate to
this film is you see a group of
characters that no you're not supposed
to live life together alone we need each
other
Woody's constantly like come on guys
come on guys it's like we're supposed to
do this journey together and I love that
1995 Bo Peep 1st 2019 Bo Peep which
version of the character do you resonate
the most with well the the 2019 version
you know I could say the same of my life
do I do I relate mostly to the 1995
version of myself or now it is there is
no point in relating to the 1995 version
because I can I'm I'm a girl who moves
on I'm I am here where I am and I I mean
Bo's fantastic who wouldn't want to be
there what's it like to sort of see her
this realized in this movie and when you
learned that and you saw sort of her
role in this movie what was it like for
you well I'm sure you heard yesterday
you know we never none of us ever saw
the whole script we did it because it's
always a it's it's like the magic
kitchen they're always back there
cooking up more stuff and just in the
moment cooking up more stuff and
everything so never saw it so it that's
just you know you have to
down like you're at the master chef's
table
it's like well what are you gonna serve
me next because the last dish was
fantastic so I you know you just you
surrender to and join that that that
current of creativity which is so much
fun and I totally trusted them too but I
must say in all of that that's that you
say that's a given
but it's more like well that's I just
have to you know they're they're on it
they know what they're doing and but
when I saw it I was overwhelmed with I
just felt like I owed them so much
thanks to I mean I'm just her voice they
are responsible for all the rest and
they they may they made her a wonderful
character I just feel like I'm I'm just
a small part of it and they just they
made her magnificent and I as I've said
I when I finished the first screening I
just kind of fell into - Josh Cooley and
I we both cried for about 10 minutes you
know I said out like how can I thank you
I that's beyond my wildest imaginations
do you have a personal favorite moment
from the Toy Story movies and I feel
like it may even be from this fourth one
um gosh there's so many I mean it's
there's there's such a densely perfect
thing it's like which bite of the Eclair
did you enjoy the most that's like I
enjoyed the whole thing um but I don't
know I have to see this one again but I
would say you know somewhere in the
final moments of four would be kind of
hard to beat in almost any animated
outing one of the themes of this film is
hard goodbye
can you talk about the theme of saying
goodbye in this franchise over the years
and saying goodbye to this franchise if
that is indeed what this film is doing
yeah it that was that was the moment
when we realized we could do this should
we try it and we tried it out and it all
of a sudden kind of earn the title of
Toy Story 4 and I will I will say that
not only in the film are they learning
that but the recording sessions with Tom
and Tim the ones were their very last
ones when they went like okay what are
we reading next and I think that's the
last line I think we're good and they
kind of really it's just they felt it
there as well so it's goodbyes are never
easy but we also knew we had to throw
the ball pretty far to make Toy Story
four worthy of being made we did not
want to make just another adventure in
the lives of these toys yeah you know
it's crazy that one of the most
anticipated characters of this film is a
spork and we see four Keys origin story
in the film but I'm curious to know four
Keys origin story as a character yeah
was it a fork at first was it a spoon
was it something completely different I
mean talking about how you came about
grading for the funny thing is he was
always a spork sparks are funny yeah ice
are well but before that we were just
joking around sitting around thinking
what would you're looking at our own
kits and how our own kids play we just
use them for reference and our kids will
pick up a rock and go do too and all of
a sudden you know it's a toy to them we
were thinking what what would happen in
the toy story world if that happened
would that Rock come to life and we just
started laughing like it's so stupid and
but then what would happen and the
answer is that that thing would come to
life and not understand anything and not
you had never seen Toy Story one through
three so there's no context for anything
that's going on and that just felt
totally new and surprised us it
surprised even woody in the audience as
well so it did felt like oh there's
something brand-new here we have to try
and it came out of like one meeting one
day in the story room that started with
that conversation and ended up with
people drawing sport characters export
was like the most popular one
no yeah nobody threw anything
differently you know it's just there's
something magical about this fork and
then on top of that we just knew this
character should feel kinda insecure and
not understand and Tony Hale we have to
we have to talk to him and he said yes
thank God you know I imagine when you're
making a Toy Story movie you're looking
obsessively over at the other Toy Story
movies right so I have to ask a favorite
moment from Toy Story over the years
throughout all of them yeah I mean toy
story 2 was the first Toy Story movie
that I worked on so that one has a
special place in my heart I loved
Jesse's backstory with the song and you
know and learning where she's been and
what she's been through it just made me
emotionally connect to her so much and
one montage scene love that moment we
would watch one two and three back to
back a lot just to make sure that
everything felt like the flow was
correct going into four and we're
continuing through for the moment that
really I love every single time is the
very beginning of the first one of the
staff meeting because that's where
you're really seeing what the world is
and how these characters are interacting
and what are you kind of going around
collecting everyone it's just it's so
charming and the thing is that they're
taking it very seriously this is their
job they're not being cute little
animals or cute little toys they're just
this is our job we've got a thing to do
so they have a staff meeting which is
amazing
you